man this this might sound crazy but uh i
think i remember you taking me to a
sixers game when i was like three or
four ah did that happen yeah
yeah that happened
[Laughter]
yo i had scalp flossies
one of my partners
yeah it didn't matter it still jumped on
my back as soon as we got home cause he
came in late uh
yeah
i never could win with that woman
so um
what happened between you two
i mean we was good for a while and then
um
and then viv and phil
started getting rich well
phil
started getting rich and then uh all of
a sudden i wasn't bringing in enough
money
um
mom said you was always trying to find
an angle scheming and [ __ ]
yeah
yeah she would put it all on me
right you know cause she never does no
wrong
truth is she's the one that put the
pressure on me to hustle hmm
so it was her idea to rob and beat that
old man half to death
[ __ ]
she pushed me on my back 24 7 365 on my
back bro
then home grateful ass never appreciated
you
watch your mouth talking about my mom
you wanna know the truth boy what's up
being with your mama was the worst
mistake i ever made in my life [ __ ] you
better chill the [ __ ] out talking about
my mom like that boy you better back up
take that base out your voice what's up
man i ain't scared of your dumbass
[ __ ]
did you touch him lou
i didn't come here to be disrespected
you ain't earned no respect
[ __ ] you're the one who came looking
for me remember i hadn't
would you showed up
that's right
i didn't think so
i was trying to get on my feet
here you go still lying you being unfair
now son don't you ever [ __ ] call me
son in your life you we earned that [ __ ]
you can walk up in here and make all
those years of lies disappear are you
crazy
that's why i'm trying to
start over and rebuild what we had you
know i'm trying to place the blame on my
mom for what you did now i got a better
idea how about you take your [ __ ] bum
ass and get the [ __ ] up out of here
i don't even want to see you again
you go find a ditch and you [ __ ] lay
in it
cause i don't need you
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
ooh he's just a boy
listen if you care about him and you
want to fix things you just
i don't you just got to give him a
little time i came here to make things
right for that boy
but he made his choice
now he's going to be the one that has to
live with the consequences not me
[Music]
you